i saw your movie at tiff
a year ago i rewatched it again last
night uh
it's as great as i remember i can't
recommend this film enough
um i really hope that everyone watches
it so anyone who's watching this
interview
please watch mosul on netflix it's
fantastic
now let's jump into why and i don't say
this about every movie but i just want
to start this interview off with that
um jumping on in um i have individual
questions for all of you guys but i'm
going to start with matthew
uh matthew this is your directorial
feature debut
uh how the f did you convince them you
know the russos and everybody to let you
make this movie
going against a lot of uh what would
make it easy
yeah um death threats uh
it was uh it's the surest way to get
anything done
i you have to ask them because i i
asked i i read luke mogelson's article
and was so grabbed by it
um and realized i'm i'm not going to be
able to
get this out of my system it it so
resonated with me and
and sunk its hooks into me and the only
way i could see
clear to to making this a movie was to
do it
in as close to the mother tongue of that
swat team as we could
and with people from that part of the
world
who unlike me
already kind of knew of the story or at
least knew
that units like this were fighting and
dying
hour by hour to take back their home and
the opportunity to tell that to the
broader world
uh was just uh
you know once kind of in a career moment
and when i told uh joe and anthony
that you know not only do i want to
write it but i also want to direct it
and i want to shoot it in arabic with
a a cast from that part of the world
none of whom look like me
no kind of special forces savior from
the west
i just want to do as much
justice to this team as i possibly could
they they didn't
flinch they didn't hang up the phone
they were game from jump street
and and readily agreed that's the only
way to tell this movie now
uh to tell the story to make this movie
and so
it was just it wasn't nearly the
the hurdle that you would you would
imagine
because they were behind it from the
get-go
and were my greatest advocates in trying
to get it done
and you know the casting was brutally
hard because
the the travel ban had just kind of gone
into effect then
so you know crew and cast and advisors
that we were
ready to bring in from iraq they
couldn't even get into morocco um
and you know it was that was the most
difficult part
the logistics it wasn't convincing
somebody to do it in the way we did it
if that makes any sense actually it does
and i something i wouldn't even think
about
one of the things that i think is so
great about this movie is that it shows
arab-speaking people
being heroes and being humans and not
being terrorists
and or just evil people um and it's
unfortunately not the norm for both of
you what was it like
reading the script for the first time
and seeing what
matthew wanted to put on screen this is
the
very very interesting question the the
first time i
i i got a call from lara tala from
jordan asked me for an interview
i'm sorry for uh audition and
she told me there's a movie i did the
audition i
really i don't know what's my parts
really just
she gave me a small uh scene but we
didn't talking about the
the parts really and uh after that
uh i got called back from uh
i had to go to london and uh
when i asked her what's going on and she
told me
i i think i told you i told her no you
didn't told me nothing about the movie
and she told me this is a american movie
a whole
in arabic in iraq they want you to be
the main character i don't know what
no no really because i never heard
american people they do they do
a whole movie in arabic you know what i
mean and
i say this is this this company uh
this project they they took a big risk
for that
and we have to be very honest with them
and
i told them give me the script first i i
read it
uh uh really carefully it was really
written really really good i want uh
to thank matthew about that because it's
like back to your question
uh this is the first time it's happened
like that
and we have to be very very careful uh
to work like with this movie and
i think we work together like really a
good team
to get it out for the audience and i
i i would love uh to say if they're
gonna like it
yeah i totally agree it's a it's an
honor to to have been
a part of this it's historical you know
i grew up uh
i grew up watching movies and uh you
know all i heard was um allahu akbar
terrorists
and you know the arabs are always the
villains and
it's 22 countries millions and millions
of people millions of people fighting
against
zero zero two percent of a minority that
exists everywhere in the world and the
cancer for humankind
terrorism you know and it goes somewhere
and grew there
so for me to to to to be a part of this
and i'm talking about with all the cast
not to have to receive an email
as i refuse it from the beginning it was
my
i don't play the these guys the
terrorists i refuse it and
you have this i couldn't believe it you
know i was like what americans do it
no way who's this matthew carnahan guy i
was like
okay okay what what what the russo
brothers oh man
okay okay okay and it's historical i
mean
thank them a hundred times and just
you don't you don't imagine the message
i receive
every day from the middle east and from
they telling me when they know the
movie's going to go out and they say and
they saw the trailer and say what is it
really is it happening
what i'm not going to have to put the
subtitles i'm not
no that's the first time you're going
gonna watch it without subtitles my
mother can watch
all my the mothers of my friend can
watch it
it's it's unbelievable it's historical
it's the first time
it's a great i mean you can imagine it's
a really pride and
and thanks a thousand times from a lot
of people
to matthew and the producers for that
yeah that's right
yeah listen i i think that people are
gonna love this movie because it's
so well done and also it's important to
shine a light on
what's going on it's it's one thing to
hear about it in the news
it's another thing to read about it in
the newspaper and it's another thing to
see it portrayed
uh on the screen with this kind of
authenticity you know and i think it can
open the eyes of a lot of people
to maybe see the human cost of what
happened in that city
from your lips to god's ear i i it's why
we made it
um and why we made it the way we did
to get at that notion that you know
everything that divides us not
everything but the vast majority
of of things that divide us are man-made
and are surface and there's
so much more that unifies us than
divides us and
in those things that unify us
are so much more fundamental
and valuable than the surface divisions
and it was it was the thing that grabbed
me about this swat team
that they're fighting in ways that i
pray to god i would have the courage
to fight in that way for those things
were i ever
in a similar situation um and
that it grabbed me and it and it
screamed out
to be told uh to a a part of the world
that
may not know these men exist for people
who are gonna watch this
uh there is a lot of action in this
movie um
a lot and you guys i believe only had 43
days
to make the film so can you each talk
about
what it was like the challenges of
trying to depict
this big story with all this action in
43 days
it was glorious i mean it was it was it
was uh
it was a blast it was you know glorious
and the blast are probably the wrong
words to use for a war movie
but uh just being with these people and
watching how enthusiastic they were
um because of i think the way we went
about making the movie
uh the the cast and crew would almost
literally run
through walls because this was such a
breath of fresh air um to do this movie
in this way
um so i i it was work
it was a lot of work but at no point
i'll just speak for myself and you guys
jump in at no point did i
ever get the sense and this
the credit has to go to the cast and
crew and the producers
to the russos and the michael rocka
and this uh bruce franklin
and mauro fiore at no point did it feel
like we bit off more than we could chew
at no point did it feel like my god
we're not going to make the day
um because we just were surrounded by
enthusiastic pros
and it was just when i say it was
glorious
it was glorious to watch them work and
to see how
how competent and quickly we were able
to do these things
um that that's that's my take
i'd love to hear what the what the guys
think the first
days it was i was i was blown away by
the
the talent of the people surrounding me
i mean i have no experience in cinema i
just had
did one film before you know and uh so
to arrive is like if you play champions
league against barcelona you know for
your second game of your life you know i
don't know if you know football but it's
like
you play against kobe bryant for the
first time he's like boom you you're
right and
the big big big these guys are really
talented
and talented in a way they they listen
they listen a lot to one another
so it goes fast when you don't have ego
there was not
much ego it was really who got the best
idea who got this and
i heard mo freyori who's the dop
and you know his big big big
listen to his third assistant who they
all speak italian he was like
and i i i heard him like i said okay
that's a great idea okay let's change it
and so everyone was
just it was this kind of energy we have
to do this and we have to do it the best
way
so from the beginning of the first days
i said okay this is how it's work it's
great to work like this and let's jump
in
and try the best to to top them you know
so it was for me it's just try to
you know to learn from them and try to
be to be as good as
as you know like your question
when you you doing movie like in 43 days
shooting
and with all this action nobody can
believe that
i think
but i think the team will work with
all of them i'm not i'm gonna i'm not
gonna choose anybody
from the director from the producer from
the
anybody anybody for the cats for all the
actors
i think there was all of them like
very very nice family to work
all of them they want to make this movie
very very professional and
and they want to make it on their on the
right way
and everybody help anybody if me if they
want me to do anything
i will go to do it nobody can say oh i
don't want to do it
okay let's take some rest no no no no no
we just matthew he said okay let's do it
again okay let's go
nobody nobody wanna uh
i i'm i'm sorry uh everybody
do it on the right way and everybody
helped everybody
it was like a family team yeah
got it so you guys were carrying lights
in between uh setups
yeah i really want to commend you both
is i really believed
um that you were soldiers that you
really
you sold me on on everything and i heard
that you guys did like a boot camp
and i hate asking the generic kind of
thing but what
what was it like training for these
roles and you know what i mean in
getting ready to depict
these people as accurately as you could
to represent these heroes go ahead
it was a necessity i mean i've never
held a gun in my life and
uh there was such a responsibility to to
to play these characters this real
character's real story i mean
the the effort gotta be endless you know
till you got it till you got it until
they were not happy till
i mean i know for my mind i've said
for me i trained like and and the guys
who trained us
it was like this i mean i trained for
real combat in my head
i didn't said to myself it was for a
film i said okay
i remember this cleaning a building we
started the first day in 5 minutes and
30 seconds i think 32 seconds
the last day we were one minute and 80
seconds
no mistake i mean we you become after 10
hours after training
you cannot like say to yourself it's for
credib i mean you become this more and
more and more and more and
for me it was real and the guy who
trained us they were unbelievable uh a
big thanks to kareem and to to sean and
to fez
they were unbelievable and put us to a
certain pace
where you know they're always saying
matthew and the director the producers
are coming
i mean and you have and they've been in
combat for your life so
we had this goal all together to train
and to be
to be proud you know that we're capable
of doing it you know
like matthew and the producer were our
first public you know when they came we
said to him okay if he believes it
now if he sees us trained and he
believes that the audience is going to
believe it
so we were trying for this and more and
more and
yeah that's it was really a an endless
effort
and determination and passion because we
loved it we loved the story
the boot camp it's helped uh it's helped
us a lot a lot
uh for for me i know a little bit about
the guns uh
rifles and whatever i don't like the
dance
but when we got the training uh
that our trainer uh sean and faz
and kareem there was very very very very
nice people
and they give us a lot of information
like what adam he said
the first time like we cleaned the the
rooms or uh
uh the streets took like with us like
maybe a
a minute and a half and uh after we
finished the
last day we did that training and we
we finished in 32nd
you know what's what's mean in 32nd and
when we get in the set
uh everybody look like this is
this is a military people this is not
these people they're not active we did
it like
like uh military professional people you
know what i mean
and this is it's helped uh helped us a
lot in the uh
in the set uh and by the way it really
looks believable on screen
um i already got a rap with you guys um
and right before i go matthew i just
have to ask obviously i thought you did
such a great job with this
do you do you have plans to direct again
do you know what you're gonna do
uh yeah i mean i have uh
assuming the world uh opens back up uh
slowly um there are two projects
uh both of which are with agbo um
that are kind of in the office
they know what they're doing over there
they keep talent they
they uh i'll work with them uh
until i no longer work they're just
they're the they're my favorites
um so yeah i have two things that are in
the hopper
one uh about uh that's set
in 1961 moscow about two brothers
one of whom was a the biggest traitor in
cia history
the younger brother is a publisher and
he goes
uh to 1961 moscow to help his brother
with his memoir and then it turns into a
spy thriller on the ground there
and then another one about uh the
earliest days of formula one racing
um where a driver
kind of wins a championship because he's
also the getaway driver for a
like a like a cray brothers kind of
crime syndicate
so they're both a blast they're both a
lot of fun
those both sound unique and interesting
yeah i gotta go where the
or the pr folks are gonna get very mad
at me um listen
again uh congratulations on the movie i
hope it's a huge hit
and thank you so much for your time
thank you thank you
greatly appreciate it